Derek Joubert: Anybody who's
spent time under the stars
like this, in Botswana
really understands.
Anybody who's listened to
this call and knows it
will know why we fell
in love with Africa.
( leopard growls )
Beverly Joubert: And if
the night sounds go quiet
it won't only be the
leopard and the lions
that we will be losing.
It will be pretty much
everything, all wildlife
and a huge part
of our own souls.
So this is a pivotal
moment in time, and sadly,
the battle is against
ignorance and greed.
Dereck: In Africa, this battle's
gonna be fought
around three major species.
Elephants that we're losing
at a rate of five an hour
lions that we're losing at
a rate of five every day
and the rhinos, we lose at
one every 6.3 hours, every day.
When these animals go extinct
people will stop coming
and indeed,
communities will suffer.
In fact, whole economies
will go down.
( audience applause )
And so, what we like to
face on is the beauty.
John Keats wrote that "Beauty
is truth and truth is beauty."
And that's what we embody
in all our work, in our films.
And the empathy that we have
when something unfolds
in front of us.
And this little scene happened
a couple of months ago.
Two lionesses wanted to cross
the river with their cubs.
But of course, they saw the
ripples of a crocodile going by.
And you could feel the tension.
And then of course, a little
later, hippos came by.
So this really freaked
the little cubs out
and they didn't wanna go.
( audience laughter )
But, the lionesses
were determined
they needed to get across.
And so, they managed
to get in the water
and they got some of the
cubs to follow with them
and straight away,
the little cubs dodged
to their side of the bank again.
This took 12 hours,
the whole day
and eventually, the lionesses
got the cubs to go in.
But, only when they were
midway did they realize
that only four cubs
were with them.
But, they had to
keep going forward.
And so, they went forward
got to the opposite side of the
bank, deposited those cubs
only to hear on the other side,
the other cubs were calling.
And so, they had to re-confront
that crocodile infested
river and go back again.
And of course, the
cubs on the other side
were thrilled to see their
mothers and wanted to play.
But, the cubs--
their mothers now heard the
other cubs on the other side
and so they were in a dilemma
and they had to try
and sort this out.
They crossed it
seven times that day.
And eventually at dusk, they
crossed the one last time.
( audience laughter )
And as they crossed
the one last time
the two little cubs
refused to go and
they had to leave these two cubs
on the other side and they went.
And obviously, the
tension in the vehicle
between Dereck and I
was extreme.
So, it was now gonna go into a
24 hour journey for these cubs.
And we waited and they waited
and at early dawn, the
two lionesses came back.
But this time, they were
almost glued together
for their own protection
and they were so silent.
And this is what happened.
( instrumental music )
( audience applause )
We were thrilled.
So, we use beautiful
stories like this sometimes
to get our message across.
And in this case,
we tweeted this
we used Instagram,
we used it on Facebook.
It went out to two million
people immediately
because everybody was
just engaged with this.
We realized just the other day
that something quite magical
has started to happen.
And in fact, people are now
taking to the streets.
This is a march for lions.
A global march that takes place
in 32 cities across
the globe right now.
Who would ever have thought
that something like this
could ever even happen?
So, Beverly was talking about
the ignorance and greed.
Something that happened
in Kenya recently
is really fighting ignorance.
As we stood at these piles
of ivory being burned
we stood in silent memory of
the elephants that we've known
and the ones that
we will never know.
Beverly: And I think,
it's important to know
that inside these piles of
ivory, 11 piles of ivory
was a lot of confiscated
big cat skins.
Lions, leopards and cheetah.
What's happening to elephants
is happening to the cats.
And then who would've
thought that
the military would be working
with us to protect rhinos
to relocate them to
a safe haven in Botswana?
So, the goal is to combat greed
and to secure large
protected landscapes.
Derek: With the big cat work
we've had the opportunity
to really focus
on what works and
what doesn't work.
And we've come down
to the notion
that there are four major
causes of declines.
Twenty five percent
of the declines
on the cats is habitat loss.
So, it's ultimately important
to protect wild landscapes.
Poaching is another major
pillar of these declines.
And so, we spent four and a half
months paddling up the river
from the Okavango to the
northern river systems
in the northern part of
Botswana, checking on poaching.
The good news is
this is the highest density
of elephants in the world
and the poaching is very low.
The bad news is, they weren't
always happy to see us.
( audience laughter )
( instrumental music )
Beverly: So, we've spent
the last 35 years
filming and focusing all our
attention on the big cats.
Protecting these
magnificent creatures.
How can you not be in awe?
How can anybody not be in
awe of this amazing lion?
But, they've led
us on a journey.
So, six years ago, we were
shocked when we discovered
that we were losing
95 percent of all these cats
in just 50 years.
That's alarming.
And so that's where
we co-founded
the Big Cat Initiative
with National Geographic.
And as you can see, we
now have great progress.
We have 91 projects
in 27 countries.
Many of them are right
through Africa.
We've managed to give out
over three million US
dollars in grants.
So, all our goal
is to now protect
these last living and
thriving big cats.
We need to be successful.
One of the other big
pillars of decline is hunting.
So, we still lose 660
largely male lions a year
to the hunting industry, and
a lot of that
comes into the USA.
One point two million
trophies in the last 10 years
into the United States.
So, we've reached out
and we've tried to do whatever
we can in this regard.
And we've spoken to
governments around the world.
We're already starting to see
some very, very interesting
things at this crossroads.
The US government has announced
that they will be restricting
lion trophies coming
into the United States.
Similar conversations are
happening in Australia
in Netherlands,
the European Community.
Everything is now
starting to close down.
We've spoken to airlines.
We started this
conversation with airlines.
There are 42 airlines today
that refuse to carry
hunting trophies.
So, we are having
quite an impact
and that's what we're
so pleased about.
And then, we need to look
at the successes in Africa.
There has been some policy
changes in governments.
Botswana stopped
all lion hunting
and then in 2011 stopped
all leopard hunting.
Twenty-fourteen,
they decided no hunting,
completely shut down.
Uganda followed in the
footsteps of Botswana
and they stopped
big cat hunting.
And now, all hunting.
South Sudan followed and they
have now stopped all hunting.
A little different
with South Africa.
South Africa has put
a moratorium on leopards,
for a year.
But that shows that we
can't be complacent
we need to drive forward.
The fourth big pillar,
of course, is communities
that live next to these
big wildlife populations
and are now in
conflict with them.
We have a
number of grantees that
are working with communities
largely to reduce the conflict
with cattle communities like
the Maasai, for instance.
One particular innovative
project that we came across
is in redirecting this
young warrior instinct
to go out and to kill a lion.
And we're trying
to find with them
new ways to direct that energy.
Even though, it's a very,
very ancient activity.
( chanting )
( instrumental music )
So this is a race
against time.
What we have to do is
stop all killings.
We have to stop all conflicts
and we need to mount
a major campaign
to stop all the trade
in animal parts
for us to be successful.
Who would've thought that
within a year of Cecil, the lion
in Zimbabwe being killed
there would be marches
in the streets
there would be government
policies being changed
there would be airlines
stopping trophy hunting?
And so for us, there's
never been a time
when the path in this
crossroads has been clearer.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
( audience applause )